Hey how's it going welcome today we're
gonna play supposedly the scariest game
of all time no one said that actually
but it says here game contains jump
scares which can cause heart attack the
risks I take the things I do they should
make a statue out of me or some [ __ ]
a lot of it also links to horror games
what happens if I click that nothing
happens that's my favorite button what
if I click start nothing either oh they
did work that way alright alright okay
we can play it amazing the game is
called scourgeth you feel cold you don't
know where you are you have to find it
peace how about I stop playing this game
that's a great way to find peace hello
oh oh look I have hands that's great
then I find peace yet it's peace here
mine what you look at I'm sorry a red
vignette means you're losing [ __ ] blue
means you're better whole life smiles to
use your arms whoa
I am apparently a Nazi this is not mine
tell this buck boy hey Errol holy books
in the house a book this is the most
this is a horror game
I keep put my god stairs the spirit of
Stefano these things disappearing I
remember them from summer goddammit
I remember them from some some foreign
ancient game from Sweden hmm
all right what do we got check every
door price lead to crouch its place to
jump all right this is my favorite game
of all time Can I grab it ha yeah what
am I wearing by the way the latest
product oh I got it I got it ha ha ha
what do I do with it what do I do with
it I'm freaking Oh God ok ok Coco come
down come down it's gonna be okay
ok ok I way to go where do you go sue
sue wait where do you go alright I'm
freaking out over here grab the light
bulb I got it I got you you son of a
[ __ ] ha ha ha
this is amazing this is amazing this is
actually kind of funny ah nope
ah alright grab it ah got it
I got jazz hands aah oh my god what
happened
Oh what the [ __ ] gravity Newton Newton
you lied let me hug you
anyone want a hug I was supposed to
leave now
toilet watch in pool by going back all
right
don't don't watch me man you can sprint
all right spinning all right
zobelle get out of here I [ __ ] slap
your zobelle
stupid you stupid oh I what are you
doing on my face
what suck my dick no wait don't do die
or poorly sue me for sexual harassment
or some stupid [ __ ] those [ __ ]
barrels all right I don't know I don't
know box the [ __ ]
what are you ow ow it's penetrating me
Oh God my it's very low click ly find
something to restore it [ __ ]
um how about books everyone likes books
oh god it's a Twilight it's not
happening well I was why was that hello
it's anybody in here how many steps am i
taking I'm taking like Oh Oh Stephano
yes yes I just have to look at them to
disappear
I'm so happy anyone want a hug another
one no touch it let's keep going
today dude it Ted Ted Ted I love this
game son
it's like my favorite game of all time
and won't budge god damn it I'm Nisha
god damn you I'm a baguette hello again
how you doing me hugs
great great thing grab it is an apply T
bug a night otherwise we might have a
problem here hey what are you doing ah
no hugs for you I was gonna hug you but
now I don't like you anymore let's see
if we can find some fired might sound
like an explosion
well well well speaking of that god
dammit you are my only friend my bucket
you were my greatest bucket I just
wanted to [ __ ] it then I saw it was a
bucket I dip my ding-dong and then I
sang this sing song ching chong ching
chong there we go we unlock that be
hello bucket stay there don't do
anything stupid like wetting yourself
Wow now I did it god damn you Jennifer
what are you doing here
my parrot I love you ah you're too fat
for love god damn your fight oh god I
fell through the map see that's how fat
you are know what don't lose
consciousness well don't make me fall
through the map then what the [ __ ] is
this well that was some weird [ __ ]
I felt through the map again alright not
fall through the mat this time huh
alright what we got it's all a dream
but why feelings are so real why can't I
wake up what is this hell this house is
awesome like we can take a bucket now
there's a broom and then we can dip it
in the bucket this is like my favorite
life I can clean all I want why would
you ever want to leave it books don't
jump like that what are this book let me
look at it let me let me have a look
it's Fifty Shades of Grey
Kelly Kelly with the broom unholy unholy
unholy I'm flying barrels Oh battles you
can fly to hug good good for you you
know it good for good for you good for
you good for you you learn how to fly
get four you get four you get sorry
I'll soap when did it it it it it it it
it it it it it it it it it it did it did
it hurt her
hey mate what if I what if I use this hi
hi shut up shut up haters I'm gonna use
this thing on you oh god you're killing
me they killed me
kill me but they kill me softly so it's
okay what the [ __ ] is going on here what
is this ah key join oh oh what what what
where was I so nuts supposed to do dead
huggin just ditched anyone want to hug
me please hug me I don't understand why
no I god damn it it happened again
whoa whoa oh the eye is looking at me
goddamn eyes these days all right what
if we just strike the eye with this
bucket
everyone loves buckets all right you go
bucket bubbles I'm scared
shower buckets aren't scared and you
shouldn't talk like that oh [ __ ] he went
into infinity I thought oh god damn it
um this way pocket what are you doing I
came back for you both
all right well nothing has changed from
last time I checked except these doors
open now let's weed and I fell off the
map again what the [ __ ] did they try
this game before they test it I wish you
had multiplayer though so you can just
hug each other
I am very lost in this game this is
could be a pack of potatoes now now
potatoes what are you doing
potatoes it's out of control the
potatoes go away stupid potatoes never
liked you anyway Josh [ __ ] Josh smack
that hole on the side smack it open
let's go down yeah yeah oh hi there
either stranger this game is really
spooks like I'm I'm scared right now
almost let's hug the light bulb that's
what we do in Sweden yes I got you now
stick woo oh my god that was amazing huh
what the [ __ ] has happened who's that I
wasn't scared that's how I scream when
I'm excited for for love that's what ah
it's like a vagina just flapping in
together disgusting the [ __ ] now trees
come on you think you can best me I have
super strength I'm the next super main
swear to God all right what does it say
don't look at them it only makes them
faster uh what what are they talking
about arrows beerus I think you should
have to come with me actually cuz I
don't really trust this in case
something goes down I'll have you with
him what the [ __ ] are you doing
uh sorry wrong boy alright alright yeah
we need to go in here of course step
aside Beryl
I won't budge well what the fudge oh god
oh god oh god oh god let's go in here
well shall we oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
rah rah bum bum bum bum better bum bum
ba da ba bum squeeze don't squeeze don't
squeeze me don't squeeze me bro don't
squeeze me don't squeeze me I'm not a ho
there we go we did it I'm a genius
woo we did it best game ever ten out of
ten
oh god what was i oh alright
what what is that I saw an eye for a
second okay don't look at me don't look
at me don't judge me up hey stop judging
what the what what is this some kind of
game some kind of video game huh what is
this what do you think I am I pellet a
million of you guys there we go I made
it in I'm not scared of no sheets up
extra soft in it and feels so nice mmm
thanks game ah that watch just looks
like a pancake isn't that peculiar
search for the exit it can be somewhere
where you were being before bucket
bucket teto bucket tell me where the
exit is I don't have time for this oh
sorry I didn't mean to do that bucket
why do you never like me is there
something wrong with my face is it
because I'm not pretty like the other
kids bucket well I don't talk to me then
stoop a stéfano hello it can be
somewhere where you've been before but
I've been in many places Singapore Sri
Lanka Sweden Germany like why am I
supposed to go I just wanted to hug
people that doesn't our god Utrecht
millennia your truck a date Ruka whoever
architecture this place it's not a very
good architecture all right this way I
have a great feeling about this way have
a great feeling about this way actually
um I'm running at the speed of light
here now what are you tricking me
I don't like tricks oh here we go hello
excuse me exit please I'll take me back
to it Sweden we did it
hey I'm Isaiah Maryam that was fun
I like that that was great good job
thank you for making this that was great
what do you think I had fun then you
have fun I still can't click horror
games hey you can't have everything
alive can you anyway thanks for watching
buzz I had a lot of fun playing and I
hope you enjoyed watching
it's a brofist for you remember to leave
a like or you will become a bike will
you take the chance I don't know you
don't look like a daredevil you're not
gonna like it now okay if you dislike
you will not become a bike now wait if
you just like it a god damn it brofist